bonjour alors
vi e plein salon doit dans le salon va
dans le salon
week-end vers l'or
[Musique]
je te dis non on va pas élever un cochon
est mené on a tout le week-end on va se
calmer mais pourquoi se poser tranquille
dans le canard et si on commandait à
manger terrain aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui j'arrive où seront
[Musique]
à tabanac
où nous signons pas en cauchemar parce
qu'il soit disant on n'a pas assez
persistante nouvelle copine n'y a pas
trop la main et a un enfant dans la
pièce
derrière toi et 1,1 point à wayne
ça va pas jeter paris dix mille dollars
qui vont pas de prix excuse c'est dit
avec fred qu'on organisera un repas
bientôt pour que tout le monde se
connaisse
c'est la cata
j'ai trouvé vraiment c'est reparti
j'ai envie qu'elle m'aime bien
ça va bien se passer
je te le dis à part atteindre
de jure je te 40
ouais
où
lebron james à la marquer contre son
camp